Hey trying to a bodybuilder voice every
bodybuilder sounds like they've been
smoking Cubans for like 20 years it's
your boy hey what
what's up plant what's up Fitness world
it's alex axiom here and I'm here to
teach you all a little bit more about
how to get that better squat form the
first thing you're gonna want to do is
buy my supplements go to a huge axis
calm and get my protein powder promo
code size remember don't buy my protein
powder if you got pussy-ass arms moving
on all [ __ ] write it out and crazy
looking just [ __ ] all over his leg god
damn it's so funny dudes that just that
just like max outt to the point of like
losing bodily function just unload
losing control it made a real squat if
you don't [ __ ] all over the god you
better leave your mark on the gym floor
and now here we go
voted for 680 like [ __ ] and crying
[Laughter]
that's basically dying defecation that's
dying very bottom of the squat
[Laughter]
just sprinkle ur all on his chin he's
got a [ __ ] boner too so it's just
hold dude everyone in the jail [ __ ]
drops the weights they're just like like
coward in one corner like what the
absolute [ __ ] just happened just covered
vomit and piss six eighty six eighty put
it down cody's is wiping his eyes he
started crying he's done holy [ __ ] he's
[Music]
our Dustin
these are dusty all in my bed all of my
wrists all on